so
you wrote this script a long time ago
and after watching the movie i'm like do
you have a lot of scripts like this just
sitting around
waiting that you can just jump back in
time you know and grab
uh the ones that came before it in a
perfect world there are probably five or
six scripts i wrote and
i i i don't think i would want to make
them and i don't think anybody else
would either so
got it it was you cutting your teeth
yeah i mean i wrote this right after a
perfect world
um and i don't know it just all kind of
was
it was locking in for me a little bit as
a writer at that point
and that's not to say that you know
movies always get made because most of
them don't
um but uh yeah yeah it only only took 28
years
yeah what i find fascinating and i could
be wrong about this is
weren't other people like clint eastwood
and steven spielberg
like at one point attached to direct
this script yeah it
how how it came about was uh i had a
blind steven
spielberg really liked the script for
perfect coral and
um so he came to me and said let's let's
find something to do together so he came
up with a blind
picture deal with warner brothers for me
to write something for steven to direct
and we pitched stuff back and forth a
little bit and then i came up with this
idea for the little things
and wrote a really long outline and
talked to him on the phone about it what
i wanted to do
and he said i really like it it's just
too dark for me right now
because he was doing schindler's list
and
um and i you know it's easily
understandable um
and so the next person for a minute was
clint eastwood that i had a relationship
with
and uh then he went off to do something
else after that it was warren beatty
and i spent a decent amount of time with
warren going
to have lunches and talking about the
script and him kind of feeling his way
through it and that never quite happened
danny devito back when he was directing
was attached and it almost seemed like
it was going to happen
but didn't uh dean pariso was very
interested in it
um and then somewhere along the way i
started directing uh you know in the
rookie in 2000
and mark johnson the producer asked me
uh you know every couple of years what
about the little things because it was a
script that people really really
enjoyed and there would be other
directors that would call about it
and i i thought well yeah if you can get
it made make it with him mark
um and i had a lit i turned it down
because i had little kids
and i thought that was a dark place to
live in for two years which is you know
what you spend on a movie directing
um then my kids went off to college and
there was these things at all there was
a confluence of
mark saying i think you should really
really open it and read it again
because i just did and i really like it
i think it's time for it
to be made and then two friends of mine
uh scott frank and brian helgeland
who were both big fans of the script had
reached out to me within three months of
each other and emailed and said
you need to do the little things i think
scott said you're an idiot if you don't
do the little things you know
being a good friend um and so i thought
well all this pushing
tells me i need to read it again and i
read it and i was terrified to read it
because i thought i'm going to see
um you know some bad writing maybe
and and i actually really really liked
it
so i mean i i changed a few things um
but it's 90 of what i wrote in 1992-93
when you cast people like this are you
sort of like tweaking the script based
on their notes and their ideas and how
much is it sort of like
denzel i love you you're a brilliant
actor but i really want to make this
script
well i think you want to make the script
in macro
i'm i'm a director that i would say that
probably
20 of the dialogue i really am specific
about like
this phrase turns this way on the page
and i'd love it to be this way
um the other eighty percent is usually
something that is does
is it clear does it move the story does
it fit better with the character than
what i wrote
you have to be malleable with it i do at
least i mean you know i know that
you know aaron sorkin is very very very
specific for me i'm more interested in
behavior
and naturalism and them making it their
own so that everybody sounds
different you know when they sign on for
a script they're signing on for the
you know the full and complete package
and you do spend a lot of time i spend a
lot of time with denzel
um and all actually all three of them um
talking about scenes not so much
rehearsal it's just about i mean
denzel's
you know always says the the universal
comes from the
specific and so the tiniest little
details that you could talk
talk about what kind of music does he
listen to what does he usually eat for
breakfast
um what kind of coat would he wear in
this scene
the more of that you can get out of the
way by the time you get to the actual
production
you we we all know exactly what we need
and how to accomplish this and then it's
just getting out of the way and letting
these three you know brilliant actors do
their thing
uh how tough was it to get this movie
green lit
because it doesn't have super heroes in
it to be
completely honest i was really surprised
that warner brothers who owned it from
1992
you know what what happened was i had
done a movie the highwayman for netflix
and they wanted to do another
they wanted to do another movie and i
had read the little things and thought i
want to do this
so the thought was mark johnson and i
said let's see if we can get it out of
warner brothers because i don't think
they will make it
i mean it's an adult drama and a
mid-range budget um
studios are really reluctant to do that
these days
and so you know talk to courtney valenti
inside warner brothers as a
friend longtime friend who was the only
person at warner brothers that had read
the script back when i wrote it
um nobody nobody was there it's all
newer people
so um i you know went to courtney and
said i'd love to try to get it out and
she goes well no promises but i'll see
what i can do
but everybody has to read it first
i said that makes sense she goes we have
to know what we're giving away and i
said no of course
okay great she calls me back two weeks
later and said i've got good news and
bad news and it's the same news
everybody
loves the script which means doesn't
mean we're going to you know
make it it just means we're probably not
going to let it go um
and then you know that they ask again
they go what are the underlying rights
and i said there are none
it was a story i made up um you know and
way back then they didn't pay me a ton
of money to write it either so there was
not much money against the script
um but you know then they they surprised
me they came in and they said physical
production people came in and said
um we came up with a we're going to
apply for the california rebate
for film just because the deadline's
coming up in a couple of days and why
not
right um but we have to put a a budget
and a schedule together
so i went through a day out of days with
them and said yeah this feels like it's
in the ballpark
you know this feels about what i think
it should be
um and they submitted it and i thought
well they'll see if they get that or not
and then i got a call and said who would
you like to play joe deacon
in in your own perfect world and so mark
johnson the producer and i talked about
it for about half a second and said
denzel washington
and uh i knew denzel because i had done
some production rewrites on
safe house and magnificent seven and
we'd spent time in south africa and cape
town south africa together
in a room talking about story um
you know so we got to know each other
and we're able to look each other in the
eyes and
come to some kind of you know a story
trust
if you will and we liked one another and
so we sent it to denzel
and he read it and said let's sit down
and talk and we did
and at the end of like an hour and a
half meeting um
you know we shook hands and said let's
let's do this thing and so all of a
sudden it was like
wow this is actually going to happen i
believe
after after 28 years you know and it all
happened quickly after that i mean
rami coming on board and then jared
coming on board
i was going to say once denzel comes on
a picture
doesn't that pretty much mean a green
light at this point with his star power
yeah yeah yeah i was gonna say uh one of
the things that i enjoy about this movie
is that it is a twist on what people
have seen before
it is not walking in the same path you
know um
and sort of talk a little bit about that
that this is not the cop movie you've
seen
yeah i i'm a big fan of of crime drama
and psychological thrillers and all
those things but i kind of remember
thinking back then in the early 90s
that they had become a bit by rote or
paint by numbers
in that you would have a first act
that was interesting and clues coming at
you that you had to decipher and
misdirections and
so you've you know got all that
happening in the first two acts and it's
always really
interesting and intriguing and then
there were so many of them that just
fell apart in the third act for me
because the bad guy
would be identified and the good guy
would chase the bad guy
and there was usually some you know
ridiculous action set piece or something
and then you know the good guy would
kill the bad guy
in some morbid but heroic fashion and
and that interested me the least of the
three parts of a three-act movie
and i thought is there a way to embrace
the genre
and subvert but subvert the genre
so that the third act is not
formulaic but it's still satisfying and
it's satisfying in a different way and
so that was the challenge and i thought
that's that's worth that's worth trying
to do yeah one of the things i also like
about the script is that
all too often in a movie like this
rami's character will meet denzel
they'll be mad at each other they'll be
fighting and all of a sudden something
happens where they're best friends
and what i like about this script is
that romney just wants to solve cases
and if this guy can help me solve a case
he's my best friend
yeah yeah no i think that's that's
thanks for saying that i i appreciate
that too that it's a
it's a slow burn between them you know
a cop just relying on a you know or
another cop to the point where they're
joined at the hip and hopefully it
happens incrementally
so that all of a sudden you realize that
in a
in some way denzel's virus
pardon the pun has passed a rami and it
sneaks up on you hopefully
yeah 100 uh is it a little nice though
with it's coming out on hbo max in
america you know the same day it's going
to be in select theaters
is it nice to not have to worry about
the opening weekend box office
i guess in in in some ways yes that's
true
i mean we all you know remember not so
long ago
when you get the call on friday talking
about the
the first screenings on the east coast
and then projecting what your domestic
uh you know gross would be for theaters
um and whether that was a thumbs up or a
thumbs down and that dictated how much
money was going to be spent
selling the movie in the near future and
you know yeah it's it's
it's it's a little weird to work on
something for two years and then have
you know in in in one in one set of
screenings on the east coast
have this is what it is um that said
it's a movie that has some scope and
la is a character and i think it's i
mean i think john schwartzman did a
beautiful job shooting it
and and we leaned heavily into a palette
that was different than my other movies
um
and i don't know i it just it plays
really really well on a big
screen so i hope people that watch on
hbo max will put it on the biggest
screen possible they have in their homes
well listen it goes without saying i
mean i preach this all the time there
no movie is going to be better at home
it's always going to be better watching
it in a movie theater because
you submerge you know you don't have
your phone you are
in you know a completely different
experience yeah um
should i miss the movie theater like you
can't believe yeah me too
you know um so i want to talk a little i
mean there's a lot of things i want to
talk about
and i want to talk about la but i don't
think i'm going to have the time so i
want to get into editing because
the editing of this movie is is
important because you need to be
dishing out information while not giving
too much information
so talk a little bit about how you
worked with your editor in crafting
detention
yeah um rob frazen and i had worked
together before
and uh have a good relationship with
regard to that but they were
excuse me when i wrote the script there
were a list of things that would point
to one conclusion and an equal number in
another list that would point to a
different conclusion so that people
might
you know actually have a valid argument
about and be able to take a side
so you have to be careful about how you
want to show everything but how much do
you show
and how much do you give away is this
too tight a shot of this clue
is this something that we like because
it goes right by it
i think in some ways we were allowed
covid was a good thing for us in that i
had already finished shooting the movie
and had kind of my first director's cut
pretty much
done by the time we got shut down so i
was able to
do another cut of the movie and send it
out to filmmaker friends
and then to get their notes and do
another one and another one because the
world was
upside down and we were all waiting so
rob and i would work now rem
you know albeit remotely which is not
ideal
but getting being able to do a bunch of
different versions and
getting closer closer closer and giving
rob
time to really do some fine cutting in
there and look for behavior and look for
eye blinks and things that we liked
um but but but yeah i mean it was
so that that that that part was great
also what was probably good for this
movie was we didn't have a preview
we didn't have a test screening which is
usually what comes out of that is
you know you've got a third of the
people say i didn't get that and you go
well the other two thirds did and it's
important for me not to try to placate
you
because you were looking at your phone
or something you know or went to the
restroom
um but test screenings do have that for
you know for a movie like this that's
trying to be smart
they're always going to play to the back
of the audience and i get that it's a
bit of business and and all that but i
think we probably benefited from having
no test screen
did you have a much longer cut of this
film that you almost
released or was it always about 210 well
i mean like every single movie that's
ever been made your you know your
initial assembly is everything
you know and it's and it's way long and
then we got pretty quickly got to
i don't know two hours and 17 minutes
which is
then it's easy the more you know about
your movie you know you go
i'm i'm taking i want to take this out
but it's not because of time
because i don't have any problem with
the movie being 217 if that's the
perfect link for it
but just as you learn more about your
movie and keep doing this doing this
doing this
we i never felt like we cut for time i
felt like we cut for
we've been here a long time now and i
feel like something needs to happen
let's jump cut this we also you know we
just from a stylistic standpoint
we're jump cutting a lot not like a
music video jump cut but just trying to
stay really electric with these guys
trying to trying to solve these things
and what they're seeing what they're
doing
um and just up cutting it a little bit
which i think kind of keeps you involved
so yes was there a longer version yes is
it a better version
no got it i want to ask you a spoiler
question which i give you my word would
not run till
the movie is completely out you know
what i mean um
and so if you want to discuss but i am
curious if you don't mind talking a
little bit about the very end
and how you came up with that ending and
was it almost
something else or was that always what
you were driving towards
i it was always what i was driving
towards and i wanted it to be
i mean i wanted it to be unexpected and
i wanted it to be
something that's almost
old testament i didn't want it to be uh
you know guns firing and this and that
and all i wanted it to be unexpected
and old testament i'll say that sure
because
the thing one of the reasons i really
dig the ending is it's
not what your typical hollywood ending
is
you know and i i've seen that ending a
thousand times i have no interest in
that ending
i'm interested in what this movie does
because it's something i have not seen
before
yeah i mean yeah i guess on the one hand
you you write it
when you're you know a young writer and
and every people read it and they love
it
um and are responding to it but it
doesn't get made because it's not
that form well this is what people
expect i mean they were they were i mean
i can't tell you how many times um
studios would say change if you change
the ending we'll make this movie
make it so we're absolutely positive who
the good guy and who the bad guy is and
we'll make this movie and i said that's
the whole reason i wrote it why would i
want to make that movie one of the
things i think is great about streaming
is that and it's already done it but
it's allowed
movies to be made that are not four
quadrant films
you know a lot of people are making one
quadrant movies
that are aiming at a very specific
audience and
genre uh obviously not for like a 200
million dollar budget but it allows
these movies to be made
is are you currently writing or
developing anything
like that stuff that you can only make
now because
of maybe the freedom that comes with
streaming yeah i mean there's no doubt i
mean i do adult dramas and it's kind of
you know those are hard they're hard to
get hard to get made um
so uh when the high women that i've been
attached to for
excuse me 15 years um
when netflix and scott stubber expressed
interest in it
that was a perfect place for that movie
because universal owned it
and loved it they just couldn't find a
way to make it work for them in probably
multiple quadrants and i get that
but netflix was a perfect place we could
come in and make that movie that i
really wanted to make
and it didn't have to it didn't have to
survive in a box office and and rely on
15 year old boys necessarily to
to sell the movie you know um i'm you
know yeah
i'm i'm adapting to direct a stephen
king novella
which is kind of more like a stand by me
than uh misery or something or it you
know it's it's
it's kind of a more of a character based
thing and it's smaller and so i think
that's that netflix is the right place
for that
too can you say what that one is or no
yeah it's called
mr harrigan's phone and it's from the uh
the book uh if it bleeds
got it i i could ask you a million other
questions but i already got to go i'm
just gonna say congrats on this
i also really enjoyed high women i hope
you're making another movie soon
hey me too me too good to see you let's
not make it seven years
hopefully not have a great day